[Music]
and almost got away news thank God you
did it unless they were trying to escape
that than hopes true submitted by 2020
is coming it is the traveler faked a
pregnancy to avoid baggage fees but was
caught seconds before boarding I mean
baggage fees could be pretty steep you
can get out of baggage fees if you're
preggers I don't know why you would she
say
you mean checkmate she stuffed her
clothes so she has our big regular she's
like I'm having a weird pregnancy I
think I think if you get a check-in bag
now it's like at least 50 bucks yes each
bag complimentary sound wants to be
Southwest is to free checked in bags hey
well they could do it now because
there's less Airlines so they're kind of
in cahoots it's like what do you call it
like an oligopoly yeah United quality is
getting shittier but then the the chard
the the prices are getting higher yeah
there's in the space is getting less and
less and they play musical chairs with
the [ __ ] gates now mm-hmm updates
like it tells you the gold like three
different [ __ ] gates yeah why why do
they do it I thought terminals were for
specific airlines like days that you can
just go to your gate and just knock out
for an hour or over if you don't pay
attention
it could be over there not well it
depends on how early you get there yeah
there's lounges too cuz I get there
pretty [ __ ] early cuz Nikki's a
maniac about traveling she's like it's
Moscow to be there for hours early I'm
like not myself to be there for hours
early but she's like into it I'm gonna
start doing that now cuz the last time I
had a sprint and I almost didn't [ __ ]
make it to my flight you know why they
don't do the shuttle service anymore to
where I park yeah so I when I got there
I was like oh [ __ ] you could you got a
[ __ ] walk you know do-over anymore
either
yeah you got a go-to verb spot so I was
I [ __ ] I had a sprint cuz I tie my
[ __ ] out to where the shuttle and
everything but I made it like
in the shuttle when they're notorious
for having a shitty shuttle service it's
usually pick up I'm never I never have a
problem with them like like when you
park because I'll usually look for a
shuttle and I wave them down so then
that's fine but then when I when you get
like what do you call it when you when
you arrive and you wait for the shuttle
there's been times when I waited an hour
why can't L a build another [ __ ]
Airport exactly like down here like like
down like but not by LAX but like closer
they got a Burbank one so anyway so this
travel writer she said that she went to
extreme lengths to avoid paying a forty
dollar charge of having a over
overweight carry-on she might not she
must not be a successful writer she can
before 40 or 50 yeah she's on she's on a
low-cost Australian airline her name is
Rebecca and she even made a video clip
about it and I will show you this video
woo a small suitcase will fit your
clothes you don't know how to pack [ __ ]
[Music]
oh so she made a video on how to do this
yeah oh that's pretty good uncomfortable
as [ __ ] to have your chords in this is a
[ __ ] comedy video but she can't do
that here with the metal detectors in
she right before she boards the plane
because this she needs is to be at the
airport and someone like Vitaly walks by
and pushes her into the fountain and all
of our electronics is [ __ ] Fri no so
she's saying that this airline is
notorious to constantly like have a
scale with them and then wave people's
bags before they they get on the plane
because it's a low budget like they go
to extreme lengths to like make sure you
follow the rules should you get money
exactly to get money and then so so she
said that she did she filmed this video
in her hotel room before going to the
airport and so when she got to the
airport she went through security and
obviously they don't weigh your bag at
security so it's right before you get on
the plane that she went to the bathroom
she put all this stuff on and so she was
about to get away with it but she was
the last passenger to board the plane so
because of that started falling out no
so because of that all the the people
the gate agents or whatever they were
they all were looking at her cheapest
the gate keepers so then she ended up
dropping her ticket as she already got
and she was like heading to the whatever
the thing is called and then so she
ended up bending over to get her ticket
and that's when her laptop popped out of
the coat and then people are like what
the so she ended up panicking she
panicked really quickly she says like
well in retrospect I probably should
have said that I had a back brace on but
she could have just been like I'm exited
like scared about someone still on my
ship
keep on my back yeah so but no so then
she ended up saying like she ratted on
herself she tried it on herself she
freaked out
so then oh they're like uh I know what
you're thinking [ __ ] I have it all you
got me pregnant I'm not pregnant I'm
actually not pregnant yeah pretty much
then she ended up having to pay the $40
fee and then boarding and looking like a
dummy yeah cuz then she started also
saying like well you know like I I just
I'm cold I have a lot of jet like a lot
of layers because I'm really cold and
they're like nah you gotta pay up that's
fine it's just wedding internal laptop
dude she doesn't have a suitcase so then
she's [ __ ] carrying her [ __ ] off the
airport suitcase was overweight oh
that's the whole plan of carrying the
extra weight on her body okay cuz I was
gonna say she doesn't know how to pack
she should roll it all that [ __ ] could
fit in there but it's not about fading
it's about the way yeah yeah I don't
understand is how are they charging you
for weight so like is it just the
arbitrary number that they put on there
so they can charge you more yeah cuz the
only like practical reasoning I can
think of is that if it falls and it hits
someone on the head from the top rack or
if it's like a Lea any over way the
planet
she overweight the planet no I'm serious
if she's on tour and [ __ ] they [ __ ]
know stuff over stuff the plane and
that's one of the causes yeah it makes
revokes I think that women should travel
a little lighter yeah I don't you know
what does it make any sense though is
like I agree they also they also put it
like it on the [ __ ] what do you call
it the under the plane right so it's the
same weight on the plane no right but
but they they're arguing that they have
to weigh the like the plaintiffs away a
certain amount to fly and [ __ ] so we're
gonna charge you for the more weight
because they know if they'll plan weighs
this much we use this much gas weighs
this much we need to use this much gas
and it cost us more money so they might
fill up more gas yeah it's like when you
drive with like a full car and full car
like your gas tank you don't use way
more gas that's their justification they
really never ride even close to [ __ ]
over stuffing the plane obviously
they're like regulation yeah but I do
think grosser pad less do - I do - okay
that's so funny I never see guys
problem guys appreciate the girls love
to carry it for you know John Devers
plane went down just on mechanical
difficulty not because he had too much
leopard print [ __ ] suitcases John
Denver you don't know John Denver and I
look at my skin yeah it's pretty white
to me and you should have gone Denver
glasses like you but he's a white guy
but what does he do he he's a singer
he's like a back to the chicken nugget
or something oh I like to the dinosaur
chicken the cowboy the Denver omelet
they don't toast evenly I will say but
they're bonded but yeah so do you guys
have any travel acts oh one thing I do
now you know when you go through TSA and
then you gotta empty out all your
pockets or whatever so now what I do is
I take my wallet my keys and myself went
out and I just put it in the cup holder
of my backpack and I just put that in
there so that when I walked through I
come back out and I just take it out a
couple and I put it back in my pockets
you know some people do which I do this
too sometimes if it's cold I put all my
[ __ ] in my jacket and I just take my
jacket off that's what I do have a
travel jacket and in a system you have a
system and then even just the before
packing like just have your toiletries
already in the suitcase like [ __ ] that
you're gonna always like have doubles
because I see people that will get their
toothbrush and then put it away I'm like
just get a separate thing and just leave
it in your leg room oh that's a dream
yeah like a hide you back yeah like your
toiletries bag like just leave it alone
like have two sets of everything one
that stays at home and one that always
travel I do that too except for my
toothbrush I just have one two three now
be God I will to this in general like
you're traveling average server so much
huh so much well she likes her teeth to
be a certain way then why did you get
two of the same thing Shay ballin like
you okay my biggest travel hack is to
drink while I watch shitty Marvel movies
and then they become pretty decent
movies and perhaps even inspirational
movies
you know movies are way better when it's
directly in it you say that I like
Marvel movies you like you could like
them but I don't find that crappy no no
I but I'm talking about the shitty ones
like Doctor Strange and stuff I know I'm
sorry
another travel hack is traveling for
practically free that's what you're
about to do okay good enough credit huh
good enough traffic yeah yeah so if you
use points that's another way like I
haven't paid for any traveling in the
last two years out of pocket it's always
been points mmm so that's another way
where airline credit cards or regular
and then you get the points for that and
you can use them travel yeah and you can
combine points too because so like some
of these credit cards they'll be like if
you sign up and you spend a thousand
bucks in the first three months you get
like 60,000 points and and that can rack
up to being like 600 bucks or whatever
and then you can combine all of them
together and you get like thousands of
dollars worth of points and that's a
free trip right now that you just wait
for the plane to take off on the runway
and before they tuck the tires just jump
on it and it closes in so that's pretty
good like Indiana Jones kind of [ __ ] huh
that's cool well Toy Story that's a good
hack too because you don't need to
breathe
[Music]